anusha how much exactly is Jurassic
world expected to make in the second
weekend so last weekend it shattered
expectations and it generated something
like 200 million for its first three
days this weekend it's at expected to
add another hundred million which would
set a new record last last weekend it
became the biggest film in the world
essentially by setting new records in
the US and overseas this weekend it will
register the second the biggest second
weekend on record for film overtaking
Disney's The Avengers incredible i
thought this franchise had died years
ago anusha so why did everyone else okay
Dino and clearly not so why can't inside
out though beat their second weekend
what's going on well to take nothing
away from this film inside out it has
had rave reviews and every screening
critics come out you know uploading it
but it's really not have the kind of
wall-to-wall publicity the Jurassic
world has and the thing about when you
have an amazing weekend at the box
office people hear about it and then
they want to go see it so really you
know it just sort of compounds things
for Jurassic world and just means that a
lot of people want to go see it now
having said that dress inside that
should open with about 60 million at the
box office which is nothing to be
sniffed out it's the numbers are in line
with say we're frozen open but frozen
did also open at number two and you know
Jurassic world's not for the younger
kids no it's not I mean I took my kids
there and I thought some of the scenes I
was like oh close your eyes so so anusha
what does this say though about
viewership and and and what viewers want
you know what's what's really
interesting is it's Universal is behind
Jurassic world and they're also going to
be behind minions which is coming out in
a few weeks which will be probably
inside our biggest issue but it it
should one they've overtaken Disney and
sort of threatened Disney's dominance of
the box office this year but it also
shows that you know in this sort of
trend in Hollywood of reviving old old
sir
forms are digging up all franchises of
doing sequel of the sequel it does show
that if you can come up with something
very different from the previous films
that you can still get a good result and
there you know people will still go to
these films the question is will they
get to see terminator will against the
admission and by no share then in the
summer